when you think of the scp foundation you
probably think of the organization being
primarily based in the united states
after all many of the anomalies we cover
here on scp explained happen to take
place in america so it's easy to lose
sight of the bigger picture the fact of
the matter is that the anomalous is not
just confined to the united states and
if it were the foundation would have a
much easier time doing its job than it
actually does unfortunately for the
foundation it's not just the us that
they have to focus their efforts on it's
the entire world that's right no matter
where you are on earth no matter how far
you travel the threat of being the
victim of an unsuspecting anomalous
incident remains the same even on your
family vacation to disney world of
course the foundation's mission is
massively expansive too with each object
requiring not only significant resources
to capture but even more to effectively
contain and study over a long period of
time and then you have the utilities of
each site keeping the power on and the
water running or what about actually
paying the hard-working scp personnel
who put their lives on the line every
day how about keeping global
reconnaissance as a watchful eye in case
of talk of any unnatural incident start
making the rounds in the ordinary world
what about maintaining a standing army
of trained task force operatives far
deadlier than any other military force
on the planet resources to cover up
events as soon as they happen field
agents database expenses it's
unimaginable to think of the costs of
operating the foundation in one country
let alone on a global scale so how do
they manage this heavy responsibility
how does the scp foundation divide up
its resources accordingly as well as
raise enough money to continue operating
think about it if you were an
organization having to cover the entire
globe in service of protecting humanity
from the anomalous what would be the
best way of managing your resources
first you need to make sure you were
backed by the richest of the rich who
could use some of their personal wealth
to fund your goals well that's the
overseer council the group at the top of
the foundation composed of some of the
most affluent and wealthy individuals in
the world second you'd make sure you had
a means of generating revenue the
foundation can't exactly open itself for
donations from the public and it can't
issue taxes but it can have others do
that for them cover-up businesses and
sourcing funding from the governments of
the world either legitimately or through
blackmailing are two surefire ways to
keep the cash flowing endlessly who
knows how many fortune 500 companies are
actually owned by the foundation there's
a lot of money in the world to go around
but someone needs to capitalize on it in
order to get it but the most important
way to manage global resources is
decentralization remember what we said
about the perception of the foundation
being us-based well it is true that the
foundation has its origins in the united
states and the country is the center of
a large number of containment efforts
but the english-speaking branch of the
foundation is far from the only one
allow us to introduce international
branches or dash int for short the
foundation likes to codify its various
branches based on the majority language
spoken there so the english-speaking
branch would cover nations such as the
united states canada and parts of europe
while in regions where chinese is spoken
the chinese branch presides over the
territory truly the containment of the
anomalous is a global effort with at
least one foundation site located in
each country africa india japan latin
america there isn't a part of the world
that the foundation doesn't have covered
and for good reason too anomalous
objects can be discovered anywhere and
everywhere having locations near all
major population centers isn't just a
luxury of having unlimited funding it is
the very thing that necessitates such
funding and with international branches
adhering to their own policies holding
their own personnel and speaking their
own languages it should come as no
surprise that they have their own
database of scp objects too that's right
each branch has an archive of files of
their own written based on objects
contained in their respective country
imagine being the guy who's just
finishing reading all the files
currently existing in the english
database when you realize then you have
to drudge through several more databases
filled with thousands upon thousands of
files just to be the completionist your
heart wants you to be it is a
time-consuming task but that's what
we're here for and today we're going to
boost your own international database
with coverage of scp-007-int
an anomaly sourced from the foundation's
global database it all started in
macerosa italy a medium-sized town
located just outside pisa it's not
famous for much well outside of hosting
the annual macerosa international piano
competition which we should remind you
that we're all very excited about this
year considering dr cleff himself has
decided he'd enter but enough about
agent ukulele's wild pianist skills
let's get back to the story at hand a
contingent of mobile task force
operatives sourced from a squad dubbed
smoking anomalous snakes who belong to
the foundation's italian branch were
stationed in the town for the past week
given that masarosa is smaller than the
average city with a population numbering
just over 22 000 these operatives had to
take extra precaution as to not give
away their presence in a town where
everyone knows everyone a gaggle of
unfamiliar faces making their way
through could set off proverbial alarms
in the local population the foundation
operatives were there for a single
purpose to source the production of
anomalous weaponry rumored to be
occurring throughout the region now why
is this a problem in the first place as
technology advances war changes along
with it sometimes necessitating the need
for more efficient weapons and inspiring
their development spears to deal with
the invading tribes on land horses and
chariots to rush those with spears bows
and arrows to combat horses war has
always made use of new technology to
make combat more efficient and deadly
and anomalous weaponry is no different
after all not every paranormal
organization holds the same ethos as the
foundation's secure contain protect
mentality there are many groups of
interest such as the dreaded chaos
insurgency or the foundation's greatest
rival the global occult coalition that
would be more than happy to utilize
research into the anomalous for military
purposes and who can blame them with
anomalous weaponry situations can be
resolved and enemies eradicated easier
and deadlier than ever before up against
a world that doesn't abide by their
mission even the foundation is forced to
utilize anomalous weaponry albeit on a
much smaller scale take task force alpha
9 last hope a squad made up entirely of
scp objects such as
scp-105 iris thompson and
scp-4494 the world's greatest arbiter of
vigilante justice otherwise known as the
spectre
even mobile task forces such as samsara
a group of heavily augmented cybernetic
super soldiers make use of anomalous
weaponry to further advance their
efficiency on the field after all task
forces spend their time combating
anomalies in the field it only makes
sense to fight fire with fire so to
speak third party sellers and producers
of anomalous weaponry often provide the
technology to establish groups of
interest so the foundation getting the
jump on a distribution center in
masarosa italy was a strategic move on
the part of the foundation they weren't
sure of the exact details but their
sources tipped them off about a gang of
fascist neo-nazis in the area working on
supplying anomalous weaponry to the
criminal underworld it's bad enough that
the trigger-happy radicals at the chaos
insurgency have access to anomalous
means of destruction imagine if every
two-bit gangster and minor criminal had
their hands on something as deadly as an
scp object and they could acquire even
more powerful equipment if they wanted
if the fascists made their money who
knows where their anomalous weaponry
would wind up the foundation wasn't sure
what they were manufacturing but they
were positive that it wasn't good their
source explicitly described it as a
weapon that could change the course of
war as they understood it a living
breathing shield naturally the
foundation was just as interested in
potentially finding a purpose for this
mystery weapon as they were in taking it
out of the hands of the black market
suppliers what uses could it hold in the
field could it provide an extra layer of
protection for the foundation operatives
the operatives were compiled from a
vanguard and reconnaissance team and
were the only ones the resource-strained
italian branch had available for the job
they spent days combing through the town
until they stumbled upon what they
believed to be a hideout for the gang
while attempting to investigate a
mysterious man ran out in front of the
team darting towards them from across
the street the team went to shoot but
hesitated after realizing that the man
was accompanied by a mysterious silver
balloon-like entity ominously floating
above his shoulder not only that but he
was wearing a full suit of protective
equipment almost like a beekeeper's suit
the operatives opened fire at the
unidentified target but before their
bullets could make contact the silver
balloon began bubbling and spread itself
across the man's body like a protective
sheet it was then they knew they found
their living shield the bullet slid
right off the man hitting the liquid
covering him and immediately being
negated by its anomalous properties then
before the team could react the liquid
shot forward detaching from the man's
body and latching onto a foundation
operative the silver gel began to writhe
and constrict attempting to absorb the
operative through his protective gear in
a quick executive decision the team lead
made the choice to put the operative who
was in the midst of being absorbed by
the gel out of his misery after all they
couldn't take risks when dealing with an
unknown anomaly especially one that they
already knew was being utilized as a
deadly weapon as soon as the body
dropped dead both the liquid and the
gang member took off through the streets
and the foundation gave pursuit the
foundation chased the man through the
narrow maze-like streets of the town
with the silver liquid tailing after
them and attempting to absorb even more
operatives thankfully the gel wasn't
fast the man however was another story
the operatives chased and chased
indiscriminately unloading a salvo of
bullets into the general area a few
struck puncturing the man's skin and
causing him to bleed following the trail
of blood the foundation was able to
corner him into a street alley but then
all of a sudden the gel burst through
the concrete wall the man was backed up
against the anomaly now larger than ever
the goo reconnected with the man
shielding him from the foundation's
firepower and allowing him to run away
and escape the foundation briefly
retreated and reconvened with their
superiors to try to find the best
strategy to move forward they then took
to the streets again searching for the
man and any trace of the anomaly they
found bits of the liquid strewn through
the streets squirming and writhing
unlike the first batch these bits were
able to be neutralized via regular
bullets their search eventually bore
fruit and they found the man patching
himself up in a nearby cellar he had a
briefcase and the area around him seemed
to be a type of laboratory still they
were unable to find the silver balloon
anomaly the operatives with weapons
drawn attempted to speak with the man
but he lashed out and shot at them
prompting them to shoot back immediately
killing him they weren't able to get
much information from him but it was an
act of self-defense the foundation now
with their only source of information
gone resorted to looking through the
rest of the basement they found a series
of documents held inside the room all
written in italian they also found a
tunnel leading outside the town and a
small cart that was intended to be used
to transport cylinders containing the
silver liquid out of masarosa the
foundation was very quick to stop this
anomaly from getting out on the black
market as it seemed like this was a
distribution and testing center but with
the man dead and the gel contained they
realized their mission was complete and
collected all remaining documents and
traces of the silver liquid anomaly in a
joint effort between the italian and
lucifer branches the liquid was
transported to brazil for further
research and classified as scp-007
the lucifen branch's board of
superintendents had made the decision
earlier that scp-007-int
held historical and research
significance for the two branches as
some of the task force members that
aided in the capture of the anomaly were
sourced from brazil the documents were
shared between both branches and
chemical research on the object was
conducted immediately the foundation
discovered the reason why the liquid
responded so quickly to the man who was
distributing it and why it works
perfectly as a living shield
scp-007-int is sentient and capable of
recognizing patterns and portraying
emotion albeit two small degrees
research into
scp-007-int's composition and responses
to stimuli in a lab environment
continued but one researcher from the
italian branch noted that this wasn't
the first time they had encountered an
anomaly like this when dealing with a
group of organizations known as the
fascist council of the occult the
foundation discovered a heavily redacted
and secret anomalous weapon with certain
properties similar to scp-007-int
while the details of this weapon were
lost to the database and above our
clearance level we can assume that due
to the nazi connection between the man
distributing the liquid and the fascist
council of the occult that portions of
scp-007-int
managed to make their way to the black
market and proliferate the criminal
underworld but when all the research was
said and done what was scp-007-int
the studies were conducted as a joint
operation between the two branches and
as a result allowed for a significant
amount of testing researchers found that
the gel was adaptable durable and
intelligent to a certain degree but they
also discovered that their data was
incredibly similar to another anomaly in
their database recorded by the lucifen
branch's predecessor the scientific
academy of the anomalous you see the
foundation hasn't been around forever
before the anomalous containment world
was decentralized and composed of tinier
organizations and this was one of them
as it turns out this organization
recorded data remarkably similar to
scp-007-int
but the details of the research was lost
due to an incident involving rogue
agents defecting from the organization
think the chaos insurgency but before
them too the two instances of the
anomaly were apparently a perfect match
to scp-007-int
and the two branches had both contained
the same anomaly across decades without
being aware that the other had done it
while the documents were lost when
defecting agents broke away from the
academy researchers theorized that they
either defected into or sold information
about the anomaly to the fascist council
who were able to improve the liquid and
turn it into a formidable military-grade
weapon still the experiments with
scp-007-int proved to be a success the
anomaly sapience allowed it to form a
bond with its host protecting and
showing the desire to comfort them if
need be what a nice little hunk of
deadly gunk right but then just as the
branches were about to give up on
finding the academy's old documentation
for scp-007-int
they happened to discover it the anomaly
was given the code name project mel this
initial research found that the anomaly
was incredibly adaptive as seen below
instance alpha is the most belligerent
case of scp-007-int
it prefers being involved in
combat-oriented exercises and watching
martial performances alpha has
demonstrated a certain degree of
infatuation to the party with in its
conception the best performance by using
its pseudo-pods in attempts to imitate
some executed movements for the
respective party to see instance beta is
an exemplary case of personality i've
witnessed beta abducting a stuffed
penguin irresponsibly given by one of
its operators to demonstrate affection
beta also displayed excitement when
presented with pictures of penguins an
extraordinary situation involving beta
happened when it parted itself its copy
assumed the form of a penguin which beta
proceeded to care for in the likeness of
an animal companion beta protected and
guided the copy through the training
course until the spontaneous expiration
thereof instance gamma possesses a
particularly high physical intelligence
it is expressly competent in solving
movement related problematics such as
obstacle courses involving the
manipulation of sensitive objects and
complex movement and transformation
patterns interestingly gamma has been
seen reacting to music by dancing to the
respective rhythm this original
documentation proved to be valuable to
the foundation as it provided further
information on what occurred when
scp-007-int was stolen from its original
location and placed into the hands of
the fascist council on december 25th
1972 several security breaches across
the academy occurred as sleeper agents
of the council stole various anomalous
assets from storehouses and vaults
across the country for two hours the
group of six rogue individuals took what
they could smuggling the objects away
from the organization for the purposes
of using and selling them to the highest
bidder objects stolen included project
mel several prototype prosthetics and
various other pieces of high security
academy documentation the foundation
also discovered that these sleeper
agents within the academy were students
researchers and operatives who had been
working with the organization for years
sometimes decades given their history
it's possible that they may have been
coerced rather than them being outright
agents of the fascist council of the
occult unfortunately all of them expired
during the interrogation procedures and
only one survived captured by the
academy via suspended animation though
their whereabouts in the present day are
unknown it's unknown if the foundation
has seen the last of scp-007-in
or if samples of the deadly adaptive
shield are still lurking in the
anomalous criminal underworld regardless
whoever possesses scp-007-int
is surely to be a formidable force for
anyone to go up against now go check out
scp-354 the red pool and
scp-006 fountain of youth for more
anomalous liquids contained by the scp
foundation